a lot of people get area 51 and Roswell
confused the true difference Mexico no
man Roswell is where the was Rockwell
brought area freedom - the whole issue
yeah yeah yeah yeah Roswell is where it
happened right where one of them
happened one of them one of the many
because we know there are nine craft
club yeah so early alien crash happened
in Roswell they did a newspaper report
whatever and then they took the alien to
area 51 area 51 is a restricted area in
Nevada right listen you guys can time my
area 51 if you want I might fall asleep
over here because Harmon heard what area
is for okay
it's supposed to be other next-level
[ __ ] is for Nexus I'm behind 50 would
okay yeah is it the mountain next to is
is adjacent to area 51 and apparently
everyone used to be a hotbed for UFO
stuff that's where they put everything
before it but then they had to move
everything because everyone started to
suspect area 51 which no [ __ ] yeah even
then [ __ ] early 90s everyone was like
err if you want the stealth bomber was
developed there rails so area s4 is what
Bob Lazar what Bob Lazar first of all
revealed to all of us what area 51 is
none of us would even know what area 51
was he's a nuclear physicist right he
was a nuclear physicist and everyone
thinks is a big hoaxster guy but I think
that Bob Lazar is legit
I think he's legit to say that I do not
because I want to Jill Rogan podcast
I've been obsessed with Bob Lazar for a
decade but Bob Lazar what he says is so
[ __ ] legit as far in so far as
the alien technology the alien tech and
how it works and like how it folds
space-time instead of like you have to
travel to between two distances like we
do now with NASA right not the way he
says it says things like a lot of people
when they speak in a way with they're
trying to pitch something like okay
there's an underlying agenda for him
like he's speaking in a way like [ __ ] I
don't want to tell anybody anything I'm
tired of all this attention but if you
guys are gonna pull it out of me this is
what I have to say and it's so
descriptive and dude if you think about
it we are doing things so stupid like
linearly right like
we take a craft in Dadar space and for
us to get to Mars we go from A to B we
just go like in linear space but Bob
Lazar saying that what this alien craft
does is it folds space-time so that you
are instantly in the place that you want
to go physical beauty
that's like magitek does it's physically
it's like [ __ ] linear travel or
whatever like how do you think I get
here I fooled space-time you take the
405 what I'm saying is it's more
creative than [ __ ] Ray Bradbury and
[ __ ] okay whatever whatever like element
that the alien alien 115 yessum whatever
that that is I think and whatever is
there power generator it's has such a
gravitational force that's how it bends
it's super heavy that makes more sense
to me when you talk about gravity but
when you just say like big magic some
technology probably combined with a
powerful force just yeah that makes more
sense
the gravitational okay and then we've
had like a little bit of disclosure
since all this bob lazar stuff right
like we had this this colonel who came
out and said like yeah we've seen these
craft we see this thing the Air Force
guy yeah and he was actually part of
like this some super squadron like he's
part of like a very elite unit is that
video a little show themselves like we
got on and [ __ ] you know like dirt
there's some [ __ ] going on that we don't
huh we don't quite know about and
instead of thinking it's all silly and
doing what the news does when they play
the x-files theme shitty people and I
think that aliens is real have fun with
this segment be you know I'm saying like
instead of that we're all treating it a
little more seriously now which i think
is bitchin
even our Defense Department has
acknowledged recently some of the UFO
stuff the British I mean the British
government has evolved has acknowledged
this stuff like in the past couple days
pacifically acknowledged that their what
that they had an entire like government
group that was investigating UFOs got
the idea for the funny hats from office
we will give it some aliens and be like
wait I got it part of what the the cat
who's talking about was saying was that
a lot of these UFOs that go into the
water or they're hovering around the
water and emerge from the water so why
what is it we don't know why we don't
know what's going on in our water they
just yeah dude it's eighty percent of
the earth and we don't a science
experiment frightening like though cuz
we don't know what's in the only James
Cameron what's it in the James Cameron
oh isn't the Mariana Trench but where he
went is one spot and that wasn't even as
deep as you can
dude it's insane like the ocean
frightens me because it's so and it's a
huge percentage of the earth erm they
don't even investigate it right so
that's the idea is that
area 51's for all these locations exist
to investigate something that the
government has denied so far until
recently and now we have people who are
officially from government who say oh no
we were definitely looking in this [ __ ]
and we see it all the time like they're
Bob lazarre's of other countries like of
China or Russia yes there are yes if
they don't get report on it be so
coincidental if all of our sightings are
only in a man no there's a lot of people
from all over the globe who have
reported weird international alien
whistle blow and there's there's a whole
group that got together and they were
actually at a conference even just two
years ago I don't watch the whole
[ __ ] thing it was it very interesting
you know what I just thought what if the
aliens are like the same thing that Star
Trek had where they where their
enterprise wasn't allowed to interact
with the actual world they weren't
supposed to you like mess around with
the actual indigenous people whatever it
was but it is just that that's what
caught my nerves right yeah they just
observed so my issue always was like
okay so if they're here what the [ __ ]
are they doing here like what do they
what do they do
why haven't they like weird why they
haven't they attacked us why haven't
they or is it or maybe studying this or
maybe they created us and they're just
watching us it's like playing The Sims
you know you're just watching off the
back drop a couple under the pool take
out the lab exact isn't that madness
though we created virtual worlds that we
just do for fun like but what if we are
in a virtual that's what I would know I
think solve three that's the simulation
theory
Parcells occupied and happy we're in one
you know why I think I think simulation
theory is real because I was just at
playlist live in Florida and I saw
someone who looks exactly Dickies cousin
it wasn't it's not genetics right I'm
like well no it's dude it's a glitch in
the system this [ __ ] was like dead on I
was like holy [ __ ] how did you make
somebody look exactly like and yet and
yet types of people - isn't it [ __ ]
interesting how there are so many types
of people and they're all the same and
they all live in different cultures
different ways on earth but they're all
kind of the same kind of person well
they said the og humans population was
like less than 10,000 and we all derived
from that DNA huh right so our variance
is gonna be like yeah cuz every single
time you go to a different country you
like you look like my friend right oh
yeah you'll have a wooded Scott come
from it Scott I think it's an alien
music yulian Jackman having a kid from
reggae and they just added trumpets
because I never got into ska and I was
like this is [ __ ] wack ass [ __ ] and I
was like from the surf into your into
your hands experiment I feel like aliens
are just up there and they just like
drop weed in different areas they just
like let's see what happens now I really
like the that kernel that are talking
about because so this guy I think he was
not only was he part of top garden like
so one of the top pilots inland in the
news Tom Cruise yeah but he's also a top
gun instructor and so he instructs other
people that go into Top Gun so he's one
of the best pilots he's in the Delta
Force of the Air Force yeah he's like
the one of the best pilots that our
nation has and so people at that level
the type of security clearance the
amount of background checks they have to
go through to like in and like how
strong his mind has to be like to be if
you were ever to be captured and to not
leak any secrets we'd interrogation like
he's just a tough reliable [ __ ]
so for him to give his first account of
what he saw coming out the ocean little
white take that I'm like man this is
[ __ ] crazy
I have a feeling like they're the
they're the facilitators are like
they're like the backstage hands and
this is the show that we're all playing
and we're inside of and
our souls are the actors and the players
and this is the game that we're in that
could be we can go on the game show too
I mean dude some of us become
millionaires some of them billionaires
and some of us die poor like we could be
all on a big game show that people watch
that people betting online with the the
religious thoughts right like so for
example like in Buddhism or Hinduism
like you have the different levels of
enlightenment so you have to go through
all these different lifetimes and stages
and then you get the whole human
experience and then you reach
enlightenment which freaking takes you
to another place yeah or heaven or
whatever right see when you reach that
level then it's like oh you you now
you're in a Valhalla or you're in
Nirvana or whatever and you're just in a
different stage we the aliens are just
Buddha coming back little Buddhists
that'll be crazy
will you take one of the pills and then
you get pulled out of the system and
you're like this like the matrix you
just die the aliens of the [ __ ]
audience just like JK news commentary
shitty [ __ ] alien trolls yeah can I
look fact [ __ ] you guys commenting on my
new clothes making fun of my hair you
guys think in the next ten years they'll
be validation if there is actual alien
might not because they're slowly we they
could be slowly winning the population
on to these ideas instead of being like
hey there's AI mean and then everyone
panics and freaks out like coronavirus
like everyone's going to buy toilet
paper and hand sanitizer it's like just
sloper cool would that do if they
freaked out anywhere they're just like
we're superior I don't care well I think
that the people same people who think
that aliens aren't real are the same
thing period right are the same people
who stood in like on continents and
thought it's only us right like in like
like five hundred years ago like it's
just us it's only Europe well think
about what two hundred years ago right
or whatever if they knew about our
technology today they'd freak the [ __ ]
out yeah man you brought somebody from
the beard just wait till we have cold
fusion dude it's gonna be you well it's
cold fusion cold fusion is where you
seen yourself sounds like a Russian
experiment you basically put a nuclear
actor anywhere and power things and like
in a small way and so then you don't
have to worry about like meltdowns and
all kinds of [ __ ] like you can you can
power huge things like [ __ ]
spacecraft like small craft like you
could change the way that humans travel
the globe like think about what we do
right now we travel the five hundred
miles an hour at max and it takes us
hours and hours and hours to get
somewhere but what if you get there
instantly that's jus what would it do to
the airport industry what would it do to
all the [ __ ] restaurants that are in
airports and all the [ __ ] things that
are there the parking that's yeah like
it's over for that whole economy
something you want to energy is is is
blowing up exponentially right so like
cuz think about it our grandparents saw
from horse to car too much it will
happen what I'm talking about will
happen and then Ryan will be known as a
[ __ ] hater
parking lot like standing outside the
air voids that's an airport you laugh
now and mean but Ryan
oh no yeah well that absent you right if
we could end that I'd be great because I
[ __ ] hate la noche in it yeah he
didn't I'm here by easily the body
scanner hey yeah it's like wow my guns
hey those guys side let's [ __ ] grab
his dick a lot
[Music]
[Music]